ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK NOTICES
THE SERGEANT AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
THE CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
ARAMBULA.
OUR QUE HAN [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
BLOOM.
BURNER **** BATH [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
CALDERON [inaudible]
CARILLO.
CERVANTES.
CHAU [inaudible]
CHEN [inaudible]
DAVID CHIU [inaudible]
CHOI [inaudible]
KANSEN CHU [inaudible]
ALI [inaudible]
COOPER [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
EGGMAN [inaudible]
FLORA [inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
FRAZIER [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GABRIEL [inaudible]
GALLAGHER.
CRISTINA GARCIA [inaudible]
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
GLORIA.
GONZALO AS GRAY [inaudible]
GRAYSON [inaudible]
HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
KILEY.
LACKEY LEVINE.
LIMON [inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN [inaudible]
MATHIS MAYES.
MCCARTY [inaudible]
MEDINA [inaudible]
MELENDEZ.
MULLIN.
MURATSUCHI [inaudible]
NAZARIAN [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE.
O'DONNELL.
PATTERSON PETRIE-NORRIS
[inaudible]
QUIRK [inaudible]
QUIRK SILVA [inaudible]
RAMOS [inaudible]
REYES THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS.
RODRIGUEZ.
RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS SANTIAGO.
SMITH [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
TEEN [inaudible]
VOEPEL [inaudible]
WALDRON [inaudible]
WEBER [inaudible]
WICKS [inaudible]
WOULD [inaudible]
MISTER SPEAKER
.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND
IN THE GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND
FOR THE PRAYER.
THE DAYS PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN
REVEREND PATTY OSHA.
REVEREND OSHITA.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
IT WAS ONLY SIX MONTHS AGO IN
JANUARY THERE WE GRIEVE THE LOSS
OF RICKY DAVIS POLICE OFFICER
NOW THE CORONA.
THIS MORNING AT TEN THEREWILL
BE A SERVICE FOR OFFICER TERROR
O'SULLIVAN IN ROSEVILLE.
SHE WAS ONLY TWENTY SIX YEARS
OLD AND ONE GRADUATING CLASS
BEHIND OFFICER CORONA.
HE WAS GUNNED DOWN WALLACE'S
TING IN A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
DISPUTE.
AGAIN I WONDER ARE WE AS A
SPECIES BY NATURE.
SENSELESSLY VIOLENT AND LACKING
ANY EMPATHY.
BUT MY MOMENTARY DESPAIR PASSES
AS I RECALL THE CARING KINDNESS
I'VE EXPERIENCED IN PEOPLE
EVERYWHERE WE'VE TRAVELED IN THE
WORLD.
NOT SU WOULD SAY.
MMHM BEAM LOVE DEEPLY COMES
DURING.
FROM LOVING DEEPLY CALMS COURAGE.
SENSING THIS TO BE TRUE.
IS CLEAR THE OFFICER
O'SULLIVAN'S YOUNG LIFE.
WAS ONE NURTURED BY DEEP LOVE.
FOR SHE WAS STRONG.
IN HER LIFE.
WAS FULL OF HOPE AND PURPOSE.%
FOR SHE LIVED CHOOSING A PATH OF
COURAGE.
ALTHOUGH AT TIMES WE MAY DESPAIR
WE MUST NEVER STOP BELIEVING IN
THE GOODNESS OF HUMANITY.
LET US OPEN OUR FLOOR SESSION
TODAY.
WHEN LIVING GRATITUDE FOR ALL
WHO DEDICATE THEMSELVES TO
MAKING OUR WORLD A BETTER PLACE?
ESPECIALLY OFFICER TERROR
O'SULLIVAN AND HER FAMILY.
NUMBER ONE THE NUMBERS TO WHAT
KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE BEYOND
WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND ASHA WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE.
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG
AS HE LEADS US IN THE FIVE
PLEASE TELL ME IN THE PLEDGE
SALUTE PLEDGE.
YEAH IT IS A LITTLE [inaudible]
YES.
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
MOVING TO THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY
CHAMBER SACRAMENTO THURSDAY JUNE
TWENTIETH TWENTY NINETEEN
RECENTLY MINUTE NINETY AM I WILL
KEVIN MULLIN SPEAKER PRO TEM OF
THIS AND THE PRESIDING CHEAPER
DEDUCTIBLES AND AT THE DESK
READING CLICK ON THE NAME LIST
READING THE ROLES CLOSER
CALDERON MOVES. TO MR FUNG
SECONDS THAT THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH.
INDICATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE INTRODUCTION AND
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNORTHERE
ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS TODAY'S ABSENCES FOR
LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS LIMON AND LOW AND FOR
ILLNESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CERVANTES.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED YOUR MOTIONS THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE ANY TEENAGER ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON HAVE
GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS.
ON THE FLOOR TODAY WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER.
THANK YOU MA'AM SPEAKER ALSO
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY WILL FORTY FIVE
POINT FIVE AND ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS CHOI THREE OF US
TO SPEAK ON IN A GERMAN IN
MEMORY TODAY WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER.
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FIFTY SIX
TO ALLOW THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE TO NOTICE THE
FOLLOWING BILLS FOR THEIR
HEARING ON WEDNESDAY JULY TENTH
PENNY RE REFER ALL.
SB FIVE BELL SB WANTED TO
JACKSON SB FIVE NINETY TWO
WIENER AND SB IX SEVENTY TWO
HILL PENDING WE WERE FOR ALL
FROM THE HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE AND AS
BEFORE FOURTEEN CAMBIADO.
PENDING RE REFER ALL FROM THE
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND TOXIC
MATERIALS COMMITTEE WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER.
AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR.
PLEASE REMOVE SB SEVEN FIFTY ONE
RUBIO FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR
THE CLERK WILL NOTE.
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FIFTY SIX
TO ALLOW THE NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTED NOTICE SB SEVEN FORTY
FOUR COMING OUT -- FOR THEIR
HEARING ON MONDAY JULY EIGHTH
PENDING RE REFER -- FROM THE
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
NINETY SIX I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO RE REFER THE
FOLLOWING BILLS TO COMMITTEE SB
THREE FIFTEEN HERTZBERG.
FROM THE JOBS ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND THE ECONOMY
COMMITTEE TO THE RULES COMMITTEE
AND SB FOUR THIRTY EIGHT
HERTZBERG FROM THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE TO THE
HEALTH COMMITTEE.
THAT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
NINETY SEVEN I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO RE REFER SB THREE
TWENTY NINE MITCHELL TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER
.
MOVING TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY
FILE [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
WE ARE MOVING TO BUSINESS ON THE
DAILY FILE ON OUR THIRD READING
FILE FILE ITEM FORTY FIVE AB
NINETY SEVEN THE CLERK WILL READ.
A SOME PEOPLE NINETY SEVEN BUT
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND ACTUALLY
THE CANNABIS DECLARED SEETHER UP
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
MR TEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AB NINETY SEVEN IS OUR
CANNABIS TRAILER BILL IT IS A
TWO THIRDS.
VOTE BECAUSE IN A MAN'S PROP
NINETY EIGHT NOT NOT PROP.
NINETY EIGHT BECAUSE IT OMITS A
PROPOSITION WHICH WHICH WAS
WHICH WAS THE OUT.
SORRY SORRY PATRICK.
THE EVERYONE'S AWAKE NOW.
IT IS A TWO THIRDS VOTE -- WHAT
IT DOES IS ALLOWS EXISTING
PROVISION LICENSES CONTINUE
UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY TWO CLEANS
UP THE CANNABIS APPEALS PANEL
STATUTE ENHANCES EQUITY GRANTS?
REQUIRES THE STATE DEPARTMENT
PUBLIC HEALTH TO ESTABLISH A
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM FOR
MANUFACTURED.
CANNABIS PRODUCTS NO LATER THAN
JULY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
STRENGTHENS ADMINISTRATIVE
PENALTIES AGAINST UNLICENSED
ACTIVITY.
WITH THAT WE RESPECT FAST FOR
AYE VOTE FOR OUR AB.
NINETY SEVEN THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN SERVER NO TO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THIS MATTER THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IN
OPPOSITION SB EIGHTY SEVEN
ALTHOUGH THIS BILL CONTAINS A
NUMBEROF SUPPORT WILL
PROVISIONS INCLUDING THE
EXTENSION OF THE AUTHORITY TO
GRANT.
PROVISIONAL LICENSES IT ALSO
FAILS TO DIRECT APPROPRIATE
RESOURCES TO SOLVING THE NUMBER
ONE PROBLEM THAT EXISTS IN THIS
INDUSTRY WHICH IS THE BLACK
MARKET.
IF WE TOOK THE RESOURCES THAT
WE'RE DEVOTING IN THIS BILL TO
HELPING PEOPLE START CANNABIS
AND JUST -- BUSINESSES AND
INSTEAD DEVOTED THEM TO
ENFORCEMENT IN THE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY WILL BENEFIT EVERYONE
IN THE INDUSTRY ARGENEAU VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER OVER **** --
MISTER JONES ARE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU AND I I URGE THIS BODY
TO SUPPORT THIS AB NINETY SEVEN
WHAT IT DOES DO.
IS HELP THE LEAGUE GET RID OF
THE LEGAL BLACK MARKET
PARTICULARLY IN MINORITY AREAS
THERE IS FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
TO HELP.
WITH MINORITY PARTICIPATION IN
THE BUSINESS SIDE OF THE LEGAL
CANNABIS BUSINESS SOMETHING
THAT'S WOEFULLY -- NEEDED THIS
AND MORE IMPORTANT SOMETHING
THAT FROM A COMMUNITY THAT'S
BEEN ADVERSELY IMPACTED BY THE
WAR ON DRUGS WHICH IS MORE OF A
WAR OR COMMUNITIES.
ESPECIALLY AFTER AMERICAN LATINO
COMMUNITIES THIS BILL FIFTY
MILLION WILL HELP US REPAIR
COMMUNITIES AND PUSH THE BLACK
MARKET OUT OF OUR COMMUNITIES.
THE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER JONES SAWYER
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER MISTER TEN
YOU MAY CLOSE.
THIS IS MY FIRST.
ONE THANK YOU THANK YOU THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ON MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS ARE TO VOTE THIS
REQUIRES
--
FIFTY FOUR IS YOUR
TEAM IS A CALL
.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM.
SEVENTY ONE SB ONE EIGHTY EIGHT
THE CLERK WILL READ SENATE BILL
ONE EIGHTY EIGHT BY SENATOR
MITCHELL AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
TO DISCRIMINATION.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COM LONGER DRIVE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS
MATTER.
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS I'M HERE
TODAY TO PRESENT SB ONE EIGHT
EIGHT THE CROWN ACT WHICH WILL
CREATE A RESPECTFUL AND OPEN
WORKPLACE FOR NATURAL HAIR.
EURO CENTRIC STANDARDS OF BEAUTY
HAVE LONG HELD THE UNDERPINNINGS
OF AMERICAN CULTURE SINCE THE
FOUNDING OF OUR SOCIETY.
DETERMINING WHAT WAS ACCEPTABLE
AND ATTRACTIVE IN THE MEDIA IN
ACADEMIC SETTINGS AND THAT WORK.
FOR CENTURIES BLACK MEN AND
WOMEN DID NOT OFTEN CHALLENGE
THE STANDARDS WE STRAIGHTENED
ARE HERE WITH HEAT OR CHEMICAL
RELAXERS TO MEET THESE EURO
CENTRIC STANDARDS.
UNTIL TWENTY SIXTEEN A GOOGLE
SEARCH. FOR UNPROFESSIONAL
HAIRSTYLES YIELDED ONLY PICTURES
OF BLACK WOMEN WITH NATURAL HAIR
OR WEAVING BRAIDS OR TWISTS.
ALTHOUGH DISHEARTENING THIS FACT
IS NOT VERY SURPRISING.
AND SO MEMBERS THE PURPOSE OF
THIS MEASURE IS TWO FOLD.
FIRST THERE IS A GREAT NEED TO
EDUCATE THE PUBLIC ABOUT THE
UNIQUE QUALITIES OF BLACK HAIR
TEXTURES AND HOW THEY RELATE. TO
NATURAL HAIR STYLES AND THE
EXPERIENCES OF BLACK PEOPLE.
SECONDS IT IS TIME TO CHALLENGE
THOSE COMMONLY HELD MYTHS AND
MISCONCEPTIONS ABOUT WHAT
DETERMINES PROFESSIONAL HAIR IN
THE WORKPLACE IN SCHOOLS IN THE
MEDIA AND EVEN IN THE MILITARY.
FOR YEARS THERE HAVE BEEN TOO
MANY CASES OF BLACK EMPLOYEES AN
APPLICANT'S DENIED EMPLOYMENT OR
PROMOTION.
AND EVEN TERMINATED BECAUSE OF
THE WAY THEY CHOOSE TO WEAR
THEIR HAIR.
SO WEARING MY HAIR AND TWISTS OR
LOCKS OR EVEN BRAIDS AND THESE
ARE COURTESY OF PRASHANTH.
SHOULD ALSO BE MINE PROTECTED
RIGHT TO CHOOSE.
SB ONE EIGHT EIGHT PROTECTS THE
RIGHT BY CLARIFYING IN THE FAIR
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING ACT.
AND IN EDUCATION CODE THAT THE
DEFINITION OF RACE IS INCLUSIVE
OF TRAITSHISTORICALLY
ASSOCIATED WITH RACE INCLUDING
BUT NOT LIMITED.
TO HAIR TEXTURE AND PROTECTIVE
HAIR STYLES THIS BILL WILL NOT
SUPERSEDE HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE
REGULAR REGULATIONS OR PREVENT
EMPLOYERS FROM ENFORCING
REASONABLE GROOMING STANDARDS
THAT RELATE TO A BONA FIDE JOB
QUALIFICATION.
THE CROWN ACT HAS ENJOYED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND HAS
RECEIVED NO NO VOTES MEMBERS IT
IS.
TWENTY NINETEEN ANY LAW THAT
SANCTIONS THE JOB DESCRIPTION
THAT IMMEDIATELY EXCLUDES ME
FROM A POSITION NOT BECAUSE OF
MY CAPABILITIES OR EXPERIENCE
BUT BECAUSE OF HOW I CHOOSE TO
WEAR MY HAIR.
IS LONG OVERDUE FOR REFORM I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY COMMA -- DOVE.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
YEAH.
YEAH WELL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTES AYE AYES FIFTY
FOUR NEWS HERE THIS MEASURE
PASSES WITHOUT OBJECTION
IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL TO THE
SENATE
.
WE WILL MOVE TO THE SECOND
READING FILE FILE ITEMS ONE
THROUGH THIRTY FIVE THE CLERK
WILL READ.
SENATE BILL TWO TWENTY THREE TWO
OH TWO AT THE MOMENT THREE
THIRTY SEVEN WITH AMENDMENTS TO
TWENTY SEVEN WITH THE MOMENT FOR
SIXTY FOUR THE MOMENTS WHEN
SIXTY EIGHT WITH AMENDMENTS TO
TWENTY SIX AT THE MOMENT.
224-284-4574 671-732-4025
576-717-01730 FIVE SOME
487-787-84570 WITH THE MOMENT
508-568-18340 WITH A MOMENT SIX
FORTY EIGHT WITH A WOMEN'S
TWENTY SEVEN AT THE MOMENT.
304-394-2391 THIRTY WITH THE
MEMONS FIVE THIRTY FIVE WITH THE
MOMENTS WHEN SIXTY DO AT THE
MOMENT FOR TWENTY FIVE WITH THE
MOMENT AND SIX A ONE OF THE
MOMENTS.
I'LL BILLS HAVE BEEN DEEMED READ
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED.
FILE ITEMS ON RECONSIDERATION OR
FILE ITEMS FORTY SIX AND FORTY
SEVEN FIVE ITEMS ON
RECONSIDERATION WILL BE
CONTINUED.
MOVING TO GUEST INTRODUCTIONS
GAS MEMBERS WE HAVE GUESTS WITH
US THE ASSEMBLY TODAY MISTER
GIBSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED IN THE
REAR IN AT THE CHAMBER TO
INTRODUCE YOUR GUESTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS.
I WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME --
JOHNNY RE MACKENZIE ALSO KNOWN
AS J. ROC.
A GRAMMY AWARD WINNER.
ARTISTS FROM THE SIXTY FOURTH
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT.
J. ROC GREW UP IN WHAT'S WHERE I
WAS BORN AND RAISED NICKERSON
GARDENS HOUSING DEVELOPMENT. FOR
MANY LIVES IN THE HOUSE OF THE
AND THE HOUSING COMMUNITY LIFE
WAS NOT EASY.
NOW J. ROC HOST A CONCERT IN
NICKERSON GARDENS WERE OVER TEN
THOUSAND GAS ATTENDS THE STAR
STUDDED CONCERT EACH AND EVERY
YEAR.
THIS CONCERT IS HOSTED BY.
OF J. ROC.
RESIDENTS FROM THE COMMUNITY
COME OUT TO SUPPORT THIS.
THIS IS A CONCERT THAT PEOPLE IN
THIS COMMUNITY NORMALLY CANNOT
AFFORD TO EVEN BUY TICKETS.
AND HE BRING CELEBRITIES FROM
ALL AROUND.
RIANA [inaudible]
BIG SHOTS [inaudible]
E..
FORTY AND KENDRICK LAMAR AND THE
LIST GOES ON AND ON IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN I HOSTED.
A TRAFFIC AMNESTY EVENT IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH LOS ANGELES
SUPERIOR COURT.
AND COMPTON -- CAREER LINK.
AND JAY ROCK USES SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORM TO ENCOURAGE THE WHAT'S
COMMUNITY TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
ATTACK IN THE TRAFFIC A TICKET
AMNESTY PROGRAM GEARING.
TOWARDS RESTORING THE DRIVER
LICENSE PRIVILEGES OF THOSE WHO
HAD LICENSE SUSPENDED.
ALSO JAY ROCK HAS ALSO DONATED
FOOD CLOTHING -- HYGIENE
PRODUCTS TO OUR HOMELESS
COMMUNITY MEMBERS IN THE WHAT'S
COMMUNITY WERE HOMELESS
ENCAMPMENTS HAVE INCREASED
TREMENDOUSLY.
HE ALSO MENTORS UP AND COMING
ARTISTS.
AND WHAT'S CONTENT AND SOUTH LA
AREA SINCE.
BEING SIDE BY TOP DAWG
ENTERTAINMENT LABEL.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK JAY ROCK
FOR TAKING TIME OUT OF HIS BUSY
SCHEDULE TO JOIN US AND ALSO
REPRESENTING THE WATCH COMMUNITY
WHICH I WAS GOING TO RAISE.
MEMBERS WOULD YOU PLEASE HELP ME
WELCOME.
GRAMMY AWARD WINNING JAY ROCK TO
OUR HOUSE
.
MISTER RAMOS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GUEST INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU I'M A MAN SPEAKER IN
TODAY I RISE TO RECOGNIZE THE
CRUISE -- CICCONE FOUNDATION ON
THIS YEAR WITH US TODAY UP IN
THE GALLERY IS GIVE THEM A A
WARM WELCOME FROM THE STATE
ASSEMBLY.
THE CRUISE -- TO CALL DONE
DACIAN IS NAMED AFTER MY COUSIN
WHO PASSED AWAY ON THE SUMMER
WIND AND RESERVATION.
IS DEEP COMMITMENT TO EDUCATION
IS WHY THE CREWS CHIKAN
FOUNDATION WAS FORMED AS A
NONPROFIT. TO HELP STUDENTS
ACHIEVE THEIR GOALS AND HAS
GIVEN THE STUDENTS FROM SAMBAR
DINO COUNTY.
THE OPPORTUNITY TO COME AND SEE
HOW THEIR GOVERNMENT WORKS FOR
THEM.
I'M GLAD TO HAVE THEM HERE TODAY
WITH ME.
AND ASK YOU TO GIVE THEM --
ANOTHER WARM WELCOME THERE IN
THE ID CAUCUS THIS GIVES A WAVE
A SHOT FROM THE ID -- THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER ROBERTS AND
WELCOME TO OUR GUESTS
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
DOCTOR WEBER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GUEST INTRODUCTION.
I YES MA'AM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
GOOD MORNING -- IT IS TRULY MY
PLEASURE TO INTRODUCE AND
WELCOME THE TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN UC DAVIS MANDELA
WASHINGTON FELLOWS TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY. FOR
JOINING US IN THE GALLERY.
THE MANDELA WASHINGTON
FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM WAS CREATED
UNDER PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA.
FOR YOUNG AFRICAN PROFESSIONAL
LEADERS OF SUB SAHARAN AFRICA.
THIS PROGRAM AND POWERS OF
FELLOWS TO ACADEMIC COURSEWORK
LEADERSHIP TRAINING AND
NETWORKING OPPORTUNITIES.
THIS YEAR'S COHORT OF TWENTY
FIVE HAS A FOCUS ON PUBLIC
MANAGEMENT WITH AN EMPHASIS ON
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT RESOURCE
MANAGEMENT AND FINANCIAL
ACCOUNTABILITY.
THE FELLOWS YOU TODAY WE ARE
BETWEEN THE AGES OF TWENTY FIVE
AND THIRTY FIVE HAVE ESTABLISHED
RECORDS OF ACCOMPLISHMENT IN
PROMOTING INNOVATION AND
POSITIVE IMPACT IN THEIR
ORGANIZATIONS INSTITUTIONS.
COMMUNITIES IN COUNTRIES.
FOLLOWING THE ACADEMIC COMPONENT
OF THE FELLOWSHIP THE FELLOWS
VISIT WASHINGTON DC FOR SUMMIT
FEATURING NETWORKING AND PANEL
DISCUSSIONS WITH U. S. LEADERS
FROM THE PUBLIC.
PRIVATE AND NONPROFIT SECTORS.
A RICH UPON RETURNING TO THEIR
HOME COUNTRIES FELLOWS CONTINUE
TO BUILD THE SKILLS THEY HAVE
DEVELOPED DURING THE VISIT TO
THE UNITED STATES.
THROUGH THESE EXPERIENCES
MANDELA WASHINGTON FELLOWS HAVE
ACCESS TO ONGOING PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AND NETWORKING
OPPORTUNITIES AS WELL AS SUPPORT
FOR THEIR IDEAS BUSINESSES AND I
PUT IN AND ORGANIZATIONS.
I WISH YOU HAD TIME TO SPEND
WITH THESE FELLOWS BECAUSE THEY
ARE TRULY SOME AMAZING YOUNG
PEOPLE.
WHO'VE COME HERE TO LEARN FROM
US AND AS ALWAYS WE LEARN A LOT
FROM THEM.
THE PERSEVERANCE THEIR CUT THEIR
DEDICATION TO THE COUNTRY AS
WELL AS THE ONGOING -- OF
PROFESSIONAL OF DEVELOPMENT AND
EXPERIENCE WILL ENRICH THE
CONTINENT OF AFRICA IMMENSELY.
I WAS PLEASED THIS MORNING TO
SPEND WELL PART OF MY MORNING
WITH THEM AND TO FIND OUT ALL
THE WONDERFUL THINGS AND THEY
ARE THEY'RE DOING AND THE PLACES
THAT THEY'RE FROM.
I'M HOPING WE ALL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE THE
DIALOGUE WE NORMALLY JUST CALM
AND THEN THEY'RE GONE -- BUT
THEY HAVE SO MANY QUESTIONS THAT
THEY NEED ANSWERED IN TERMS OF
WHO WE ARE AND AND WHO WE
REPRESENT AND AND WHAT IS
HAPPENING IN CALIFORNIA.
SOME PLEASE IF THEY COME FROM
THE FOLLOWING COUNTRIES THERE
FROM GHANA AND THE BOTH OF YOU
KNOW I'VE I'VE VISITED ALMOST
ALL OF THE COUNTRIES ON THIS
LIST.
THERE FROM GHANA LIBERIA.
SIERRA LEONE WHICH IS WHERE MY
FAMILY IS FROM WITH THE TOO MANY
TRIBES.
GAMBIA MARIE'S JUST.
ETHIOPIA NIGERIA.
OF LOOKING OF FAST SO THE CONGO
THE REPUBLIC OF THE CONGO SOUTH
AFRICA NAMIBIA AND THIS IS DAN
ALLOWING KENYA VERY FROM THE SEA
SHELLS MADAGASCAR ARE. TO WALK
LOTS WANNA.
MOVES IN MOZAMBIQUE AND ETHIOPIA
SO WE'RE PLEASED TO HAVE THESE
OF FELLOWS WITH US TODAY AND I
WANT YOU TO GIVE THEM A WARM
WELCOME.
AS A VISIT OUR CAPITAL AND
OBVIOUSLY LEARN A LOT FROM US AS
WE LEARN FROM THEM I WANT TO
WELCOME THEM TO THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSEMBLY.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER IN A WARM
WELCOME TO ALL OF OUR GUESTS
TODAY
.
MR TING IS PREPARED TO LIFT THE
CALL ON FILE ITEM FORTY FIVE AB
NINETY SEVEN THE CLERK WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESERTED
THE ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE.
REQUIRES
.
FIFTY FOUR OUR MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESERVE A CLICK WELL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE.
I FIFTY FIVE KNOWS ELEVEN ON THE
URGENCY AYE AYES FIFTY FIVE
KNOWS ELEVEN ON THE BILL SENATE
AMENDMENTS CONCURRED IN WITHOUT
OBJECTION IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL
TO THE GOVERNOR
.
WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO
CONCURRENCE IS.
FILE ITEM THIRTY SEVEN AB SEVEN
EIGHTY ONE THE CLERK WILL READ A
SOME LEGAL SEVEN EIGHTY ONE BY
SOMETHING MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN AND
ACTUALLY MEDI CAL.
MR MAIENSCHEIN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB SEVEN
ANYONE IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE SENATE
PROVIDE PARENTS WITH THE ABILITY
TO USE PEDIATRIC DAY.
HEALTH CARE SERVICES THE
AMENDMENTS CLARIFY PARENTS WERE
ABLE TO USE THESE SERVICES ANY
GIVEN DAY OF THE WEEK AS LONG AS
THEY DO NOT EXCEED A
PREDETERMINED AMOUNT.
BY EXISTING LAW I THIS BILL MAKE
SURE THAT CARE AND SERVICES ARE
AVAILABLE CHILDREN AND PARENTS
IN A SAFE SKILLED AND NURTURING
SETTING THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I ABOUT.
THANK YOU MR MAIENSCHEIN SEEING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ALL
MEMBERS VOTED A THIRD OF THE ALL
MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
QUIRK WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTES AYE AYES FIFTY
FOUR NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING A FILE ITEM FORTY ONE AB
FOURTEEN TWENTY NINE THE CLERK
WILL READ SOME LEGAL FOURTEEN
TWENTY NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
TEN AND ACTUALLY TO HAZARDOUS
MATERIALS.
MR CHAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB FOURTEEN
TWENTY NINE IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE WITH MINOR
CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS FROM THE
SENATE.
THE BILL HAS RECEIVED ZERO NO
VOTES HAS NOT CONSENT THROUGH
BOTH CHAMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIGHT VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAN SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE
MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
QUIRK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY SIX NO.
ZERO THE SENTIMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN
.
MOVING BACK TO THE THIRD READING
FILE FILE ITEM.
FILE ITEM FIFTY FOUR AJ ARE
EIGHTEEN THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY JOINT RESOLUTION
EIGHTEEN BY SOMETHING NUMBER
THREE OF US AND OTHERS RELATIVE
THE SANTA MONICA MOUNTAINS
NATIONAL RECREATION AREA.
THREE OF US YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS RESOLUTION.
I THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
AND MEMBERS AG ARE EIGHTEEN
URGES THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
ENACT HOUSE RESOLUTION SEVENTY
NO WAIT THAT WAS INTRODUCED BY
CONGRESSMAN ADAM SCHIFF EARLIER
THIS YEAR TO HAVE TO ADD A
HUNDRED NINETY ONE THOUSAND
ACRES.
OF THE RIM OF THE VALLEY
CORRIDOR TO THE SANTA MONICA
NATIONAL RECREATION AREA
SAFEGUARDING GREEN SPACES LIKE
THE RIM OF THE VALLEY IS
ESSENTIAL FOR THE WELL BEING OF
ALL CALIFORNIANS SINCE GREEN
SPACES.
DECREASE AIR POLLUTANTS AND
IMPROVE THE PHYSICALAND MENTAL
HEALTH OF THOSE WHO HAVE ACCESS
TO THEM.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AIBO AND WOULD LIKE TO
OPEN THE FIRST ROLE FOR CO
AUTHORS.
THANK YOU MISS RIVAS SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE
MATTER THE FIRST ROLE WILL BE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS.
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON AJ ARE --
EIGHTEEN ALL MEMBERS THIRTY
DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
WHERE WELL?
CLOSE THE ROLLING TALLY THE VOTE
THERE FORTY NINE CO AUTHORS ON
AG ARE.
EIGHTEEN A TERRACE REQUIRE ROLL
CALL VOTE THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. EIGHTEEN ALL MEMBERS
VOTED AS OUR TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
WORK WELL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTE.
I FIFTY FOUR NO ZERO THIS
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED
.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM FIFTY FIVE
AJ ARE NINETEEN THE CLERK WILL
READ THAT'S ON THE JOINT
RESOLUTION NINETEEN BY SOMETHING
MEMBER GLORIA AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO REFUGEES.
SIR GLORIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THISRESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER --
MEMBERS I RISE THIS MORNING ON
BEHALF OF THE API LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS TO RESENT AG ARE NINETEEN
WHICH CALLS UPON THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO RESETTLE ALL
THIRTY THOUSAND REFUGEES.
THE UNITED STATES IS COMMITTED
TO RESETTLE IN FISCAL YEAR.
TWENTY NINETEEN CALIFORNIA HAS
LONG BEEN HOME.
A WELCOMING HOME FOR REFUGEES
RESETTLED INTO OUR COMMUNITIES
REFUGEE RESETTLEMENT IS A
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT THE
REQUIRES THAT FEDERAL STATE
COUNTY AND LOCAL AND NONPROFIT
ENTITIES ALL TO WORK TOGETHER.
AND SO IT'S OF UTMOST IMPORTANCE
THAT EVERYONE COMES TOGETHER AS
A UNITED FRONT. TO RESETTLE
THESE FOLKS WHO NEED A HOME.
HOWEVER THIS IS NOT BEEN THE
CASE AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL FOR
SOME YEARS THE CURRENT
PRESIDENTIAL ADMINISTRATION HAS
DRASTICALLY CUT THE NATION'S
REFUGEE ARRIVALS AND EFFECTIVELY
ELIMINATED.
ALMOST HALF OF ALL REFUGEE
RESETTLEMENT SPOTS AVAILABLE IN
THE ENTIRE WORLD.
THE UNITED STATES IS WELCOME
FEWER THAN ELEVEN THOUSAND
REFUGEES SO FAR THIS YEAR.
WHERE NEARLY HALF WAY THROUGH
THIS YEAR?
AT THIS RATE THE ADMINISTRATION
WILL COME NOWHERE NEAR THE
RESETTLING TO THIRTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE GOAL THAT HAD HAD THEY
HAD BEEN SET.
A GOAL WHICH PALES IN COMPARISON
TO THE HISTORIC AVERAGE
COMMITMENT OF NINETY FIVE
THOUSAND REFUGEES ANNUALLY.
CONGRESS AND THE PRESIDENTIAL
ADMINISTRATION HAVE AN
OBLIGATION TO CONTINUE TO STAND.
IN SUPPORT OF THIS INCREDIBLY
VALUABLE POPULATION AS WE HAVE
HISTORICALLY DONE IN THE PAST
MEMBERS I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
ON AJ ARE.
NINETEEN THANK YOU MISTER GLORIA
MISS BARKIN YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS.
I RISE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE JEWISH
CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF AJ ARE.
NINETEEN I'D LIKE TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO FOR
BRINGING FORWARD THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE.
THE JEWISH COMMUNITY KNOWS ALL
TOO WELL WHAT IT IS LIKE TO SEEK
REFUGE.
IN THE NINETEEN FORTIES MY
FAMILY CAME HERE.
FLEEING THE HOLOCAUST SEEKING
REFUGE ON OUR SHORES.
AND THEY WERE GIVEN THAT REFUGE
AND I'M STANDING HERE TODAY
BECAUSE OF IT.
SO MANY THAT WEREN'T GIVEN
SAFETY ON THE SHORES WERE TURNED
BACK AND PERSECUTED IN THE
HOLOCAUST.
SO THE IMPORTANCE OF THE WORK
THAT WE DO IS OF CLEAR CLEAR
AWARENESS TO THE JEWISH CAUCUS.
AS THE PRESIDENT OF HIGHEST HE
SAID WE USED TO HELP REFUGEES
BECAUSE THEY WERE JEWISH.
BUT NOW WE HELP REFUGEES BECAUSE
WE ARE JEWISH. FOR YEARS THE
HEBREW IMMIGRANT AID SOCIETY HAS
STOOD FOR A WORLD IN WHICH
REFUGEES FIND WELCOME.
SAFETY AND FREEDOM.
IN FACT HI THIS WAS THE
ORGANIZATION THAT FED MY FAMILY
MEALS IN NEW YORK WHEN THEY
ARRIVED.
JEWISH TRADITION HIGHLIGHTS THE
IMPORTANCE OF JUSTIN EQUAL
TREATMENT FOR THOSE WHO ARE MOST
VULNERABLE SUCH AS OUR REFUGEES
AND IMMIGRANTS.
THE TORAH TEACHES US THAT WHEN A
STRANGER RESIDES WITH YOU IN
YOUR LAND.
YOU SHALL NOT DO THEM WRONG.
THE STRANGER WHO RESIDES WITH
YOU SHALL BE TO YOU AS ONE OF
YOUR CITIZENS.
YOU SHALL LOVE THEM AS YOURSELF
FOR YOU WERE STRANGERS IN THE
LAND OF EGYPT.
WE CANNOT TURN OUR BACKS ON
THOSE WHO NEED OUR HELP.
AND SO AS A JEWISH CAUCUS WE
STAND IN SUPPORT OF REFUGEES AND
OF THIS RESOLUTION.
I THINK THE AUTHOR AGAIN FOR
BRINGING THIS MEASURE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER BAUER K. ON MRS
CARILLO.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I AM PROUD TO RISE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LATINO
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF
HR.
NINETEEN A RESOLUTION THAT
EXPRESSES SUPPORT IN WELCOMING
UP FOR ALL REFUGEES.
COMING TO OUR STATE.
THE DECISION TO LEAVE ONE'S HOME
COUNTRY IS NEVER AN EASY
DECISION.
OFTEN PEOPLE ARE FAMILIES ARE
LEAVING THEIR LOVED ONES FAMILY
NEIGHBORHOODS AND THEIR WAY OF
LIFE.
REFUGEES HAVE MADE THE
INCREDIBLY HARD DECISION TO
LEAVE THEIR HOMES IN ORDER TO
ESCAPE WAR GENDER BASED VIOLENCE
PERSECUTION OVER THERE.
LGBTQ IDENTITY ECONOMIC
DESTITUTE AND SO MANY OTHER
ISSUES THAT MAKE LIFE IN THEIR
HOME COUNTRIES NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE.
FOR SO MANY REFUGEES AND
IMMIGRANTS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN THEIR HOME
AWAY FROM HOME MUCH LIKE MY OWN
FAMILY.
THEY ARE OUR STUDENTS OUR
TEACHERS OUR NEIGHBORS AND OUR
CONSTITUENTS.
THEY ARE CALIFORNIANS IN
CALIFORNIA HAS ALWAYS SOUGHT TO
EMBRACE ITS DIVERSITY.
WITH SO MANY HOSTILE AND
UNWELCOMING MESSAGES FROM
COUNTRIES WHO RECEIVE REFUGEES.
THIS RESOLUTION WILL PROVIDE A
MUCH NEEDED AFFIRMATION.
THE REFUGEES ARE WELCOME.
AND THAT REFUGEES ARE VALUED.
THIS RESOLUTION BRINGS ATTENTION
TO THE LIVES LOST.
OF OSCAR I BET THE MARTINEZ FROM
MEAT IS.
A TWENTY FIVE YEAR OLD FATHER
WHO DROWNED ALONG SIZE HIS TWO
YEAR OLD DAUGHTER.
ANGIE BY LYDIA.
AS HE TRIED TO RESCUE HER FROM
THE CURRENTS OF THE RIO GRANDE.
THEY WERE FLEEING MY HOME
COUNTRY OF EL SALVADOR.
IN SEARCH OF A BETTER LIFE HERE
IN THE UNITED STATES.
HIS WIFE TANYA THE MOTHER OF
ANGIE A PRECIOUS AN INNOCENT
CHILD.
SCREAMED IN HORROR FROM THE
BANKS OF THE RIVER AS THIS
TRAGEDY UNFOLDED.
THE PHOTO OF THEIR BODIES LYING
FACE DOWN TOGETHER.
ALONG SIDE THE BANKS OF THE
RIVER ACROSS BROWNSVILLE TEXAS
HAVE BEEN SHARED ACROSS THE
WORLD.
THEIR PHOTO IS A REMINDER OF THE
TWENTY FUND FOR THE TWENTY
FIFTEEN PHOTO.
A MILLION CURTI A THREE YEAR OLD
BOY FROM SYRIA WHOSE BODY WASHED
ASHORE BEACH IN TURKEY.
AND SPARKED A WORLDWIDE
CONVERSATION ON THE
MEDITERRANEAN REFUGEE CRISIS.
IMAGES OF OUR SHARED HUMANITY.
HAVE OFTEN CHANGE THE COURSE.
OF OUR HISTORY BUT THEY MIGHT
THEY MUST FIRST CHANGE.
OUR HEARTS AND OUR MINDS AND OUR
SOCIETY.
IN THEIR MEMORY AND THE MEMORY
OF SO MANY OTHERS.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS CARILLO DOCTOR
WEBER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON THIS
RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I TO RISE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS.
I RISE IN HONOR OF WORLD REFUGEE
DAY.
TODAY WE HAVE THE HIGHEST NUMBER
REFUGEES IN RECORDED HISTORY.
AROUND THE WORLD OVER TWENTY TWO
MILLION PEOPLE ARE FORCED FROM
THEIR HOMES TO FLEE PERSECUTION
AND VIOLENCE.
THESE INDIVIDUALS OFTEN LEAVE
MUCH BEHIND INCLUDING THEIR JOB
THEIR FRIENDS AND THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
THEY'VE BEEN EMBARK ON A LONG
AND SOMETIMES DANGEROUS JOURNEY
TO TRY TO GET TO SAFETY.
IN THEIR NEW HOMES REFUGEES
OFTEN FACE MANY CHALLENGES TO
GAIN ASYLUM AND TO HEAL FROM THE
TRAUMA.
IT IS MOST ESSENTIAL THAT WE
WELCOME THESE VULNERABLE
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES WITH
COMPASSION REGARDLESS OF THE
RACE RELIGION GENDER IDENTITY OR
SEXUAL ORIENTATION.
THIS COMPASSION MUST BE
REFLECTED IN IN IN OUR REFUGEE
SETTLEMENT POLICIES AND WE MUST
SUPPORT SUPPORT THEM IN CREATING
A NEW LIFE.
I CAN REMEMBER IN APPROXIMATELY
NINETEEN NINETY WHEN THE FIRST --
ERITREANS AND SOMALIANS CAME TO
CALIFORNIA.
AND THEY WERE ALL SETTLED IN SAN
DIEGO.
AND I GOT A CALL ONE WEEKEND
SAYING THAT THERE WILL BE AN
ADDITIONAL COUPLE OF TWENTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE IN SAN DIEGO AND
AND MANY OF THEM WILL BE IN YOUR
SCHOOL DISTRICT.
AND SO WE HAD A TREMENDOUS
CHALLENGE OF TRYING TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY WERE WELCOMED.
AND I WAS PROUD OF THE FACT THAT
OUR SCHOOLS AND OUR COUNSELORS
TOOK THEM IN UNDERSTOOD THE
CHALLENGES THAT WOULD BE A TRIED
TO MAKE A PLACE FOR THEM.
IN OUR SCHOOLS AND HIRED
INDIVIDUALS TO COME IT AND TO TO
BASICALLY MAKE THE TRANSITION TO
CALIFORNIA SAN DIEGO A SMOOTH
TRANSITION.
AND IT'S INTERESTING THAT I SEE
AS I SEE THE YOUNG PEOPLE TODAY
WHO WERE ONCE A PART OF THAT --
THAT WHOLE TRANSITION THAT
OCCURRED I SAW THE BRILLIANCE OF
THE YOUNG FOLKS THAT ARE THERE
THAT ARE NOW SERVING IN OUR
COMMUNITIES SOME TWENTY THIRTY
YEARS LATER WILL REALLY MAKING A
DIFFERENCE.
THE YOUNG MAN WHO WON THE FIRST
AMERICANS TO WIN THE THE THE
MARATHON IN NEW YORK OF THE
BOSTON MARATHON OF WAS THERE AND
HE WAS A MAN HE WAS A PART OF
THE IMMIGRANTS.
AND THE REFUGEE COMMUNITY
INSTEAD DIEGO HE MADE HIS FAMILY
IMMEDIATELY BEGAN TO RUN
EVERYWHERE AND THEY WERE WINNING
ALL KINDS OF RACES IN THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
AND I REMEMBER CELEBRATING HIM
AT SCHOOL BOARD MEETINGS AND NOW
ALL OF A SUDDEN HE'S A
CELEBRATED THE CROWN THE WORLD
AND AND WAS PROMISING TO COME
HERE. TO MEET US AND I THINK
ABOUT HIM BECAUSE HE WAS A
REFUGEE HIS FAMILY WAS THEY CAME
HERE WITHOUT ANYTHING.
AND THEY WILL EMBRACE
FORTUNATELY BY THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY WHO FORMED A
NUMBER OF ALLIANCES TO MAKE SURE
THAT SOME THE TRANSITION WAS
MOVED.
BECAUSE THEY REALIZE THAT
OFTENTIMES THE RECEPTION OF OF
OF THE REFUGEE IS NOT AFRICAN IS
NOT AFRICAN AMERICAN AND AS A
RESULT WE HAVE A TENDENCY TO NOT
INCLUDE THEM IN THE ONGOING
DISCUSSIONS THAT ARE THERE ABOUT
HOW DO WE CREATE.
A SMOOTH TRANSITION HOW DO WE
HONOR THEIR ETHNICITY IN THE
CULTURE OF THESE INDIVIDUALS
THAT COME IN.
A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT THAN US
WILL DO THINGS DIFFERENTLY BUT
NONE THE LESS VALUE THEM AS
INDIVIDUALS AND MAKING SURE
THEY'RE PART OF IT.
SAN DIEGO HAS AN AMAZING REFUGEE
COMMUNITY NOW THAT HAS BEEN
COMPLETELY INTEGRATED INTO OUR
SCHOOLS AND OUR COMMUNITIES AND
AND MAKES US PROUD EVERYDAY WHEN
WE SEE THEM WE SEE THE KIND OF
WORK THAT THEY'RE DOING AND THE
THINGS THAT THEY'VE CONTRIBUTED
TO US.
SO IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT WE
THINK ABOUT WHO WE ARE AS A
COUNTRY.
A COUNTRY MADE OF REFUGEES
BASICALLY FOLKS WHO COME FROM
PLACES EVEN THE FIRST ONES WHO
CAME HERE WERE FLEEING SO CALL
RELIGIOUS PERSECUTION LOOKING
FOR A PLACE IN WHICH THEY COULD
LIVE.
IN PEACE AND HARMONY WITH OTHERS
THAT'S WHO WE ARE THAT'S WHAT
THIS NATION IS ABOUT AND AS A
RESULT WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY
AN ONGOING RESPONSIBILITY TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT THIS NATION
REMAINS A PLACE A SAFE PLACE.
FOR PEOPLE TO COME IT IS A PART
OF THE LEGACY AND FOR US TO DENY
THAT AS OUR LEGACY IS TO DENY
WHO WE ARE.
IT IS DOES NOT ALL THOSE WHO
STRUGGLE SO HARD TO GIVE A
FOUNDATION TO THIS NATION TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY HAVE A PLACE
TO STAY.
AFRICAN AMERICANS WOULD NEVER
REFUGEES WE KNOW THAT THEY
DIDN'T COME TO THIS COUNTRY
WILLINGLY NOBODY SEEKING A SAFE
HAVEN.
AND SO WE UNDERSTAND WHAT IT'S
LIKE TO BE LEFT OUT BE LOCKED
OUT AND DO NOT BE GIVEN A FULL
CHANCE AND OPPORTUNITY AND AS A
RESULT OF THAT THE COMPASSION IS
GREAT IN OUR COMMUNITY SO THOSE
WILL COME.
AND THEY AN INTERFACE WITH OUR
CHURCHES OUR COMMUNITY OUR
SOCIAL ORGANIZATIONS AND NOW
WE'RE PART OF REALLY THE FABRIC
OF THE LEADERSHIP OF OUR
COMMUNITY SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
WHEN I BILLS AG ARE.
NINETEEN THANK YOU DOCTOR EVER
THIS RUBIO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THIS RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AJ
ARE.
NINETEEN I ALSO RISE AS AN
IMMIGRANT WOMAN WHO EMPATHIZES
WITH COUNTLESS WOMEN AROUND THE
WORLD WHO SHARE MY BACKGROUND OF
LEAVING THEIR HOME IN HOPES FOR
A BETTER LIFE.
EVEN IN TWENTY NINETEEN THERE
ARE SOCIETIES WHERE WOMEN AND
GIRLS FACE VIOLENCE AND
DISCRIMINATION JUST BECAUSE OF
THEIR THEIR SEX.
HALF OF ALWAYS REFUGEES ARE
WOMEN AND THOSE THAT ARE
UNACCOMPANIED PREGNANT UNMARRIED
DISABLED OR ELDERLY ELDERLY ARE
ESPECIALLY VULNERABLE TO ABUSE
AND EXPLOITATION.
THIS RESOLUTION BRINGS ATTENTION
TO THE VAST NUMBER OF REFUGEES
WORLDWIDE AND THE BENEFITS THEY
BRING TO OUR STATE.
WOMEN REFUGEES FLEE TO IMPROVE
THEIR LIVES AND THE LIVES OF
THEIR CHILDREN. THREE STRENGTH
AND RESILIENCE THEY CHANGED
THEIR LIVES AND BRING THEIR
EXPERIENCES SURE THEIR CULTURES
AND TRADITIONS WITH OUR
COMMUNITIES WE WELCOME YOU.
I STRONGLY URGE AND I VOTE ON AJ
ARE.
NINETEEN THANK YOU MISTER GRAHAM
SEGMENT YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THIS RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MATT MENACE SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE LGBTQ **** TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF A G. R..
NINETEEN I THANK MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN DIEGO FOR BEING BRING
THIS FORWARD AND THE STATE ALL
REFUGEES ESPECIALLY MY LGBT
BROTHERS AND SISTERS YOU ARE
WELCOME HERE.
NO MATTER YOUR RACE YOUR
RELIGION YOUR NATIONALITY YOUR
COUNT COUNTRY OF ORIGIN YOUR
SEXUAL ORIENTATION OR GENDER
IDENTITY.
WELL THE REFUGEE CRISIS MAY HAVE
STARTED IN THE MIDDLE EAST IN
EUROPE WE NOW HAVE ANOTHER
REFUGEE CRISIS RIGHT HERE IN OUR
OWN SOUTHERN BORDER.
MEN WOMEN AND CHILDREN FROM ALL
OVER THE WORLD RISK THEIR LIVES
TO ENTER THE UNITED STATES TO
FIND A SAFE HAVEN FROM THE REAL
PERSECUTION.
THEY FACE IN THEIR HOME
COUNTRIES JUST A FEW DAYS AGO ON
THIS FLOOR WE CELEBRATE OUR
PRIDE CEREMONY AND THIS WE CAN
IN NEW YORK WE CELEBRATING FIFTY
YEARS OF THE PRIDE MOVEMENT.
WAS STONE WALL IN NEW YORK CITY
FOR THE WHOLE WITH THE WHOLE
WORLD COMING TO JOIN US.
MEANWHILE WE KNOW THAT SEVENTY
COUNTRIES STILL CRIMINALIZE LGBT
PEOPLE TEN OF THOSE COUNTRIES
STILL RESERVE THE DEATH PENALTY
FOR PEOPLE JUST LIKE MYSELF AND
MY FELLOW COLLEAGUES LGBT CAUCUS.
SIMPLY FOR BEING WHO WE ARE ARE
STONED TO DEATH.
AT OUR SOUTHERN BORDER
TRANSMITIDO ON AS ALL OTHER
DETAIN IMMIGRANTS TRANCE BEFORE
PARTICULAR TRANS WOMEN HAVE
CONSISTENTLY REPORTED HARASSMENT
ASSAULT.
RAPE ALL BASED ON THEIR GENDER
IDENTITY.
AND LAST YEAR WHEN TRANS WOMAN
ROCKS AND HERNANDEZ DIED IN ICE
CUSTODY AND ANOTHER JOHANNA
MEDINA LEóN DIED FOUR DAYS
LATER AFTER BEING BEING RELEASED.
THESE WOMAN FLED TO UNITED
STATES TO LIVE THEIR AUTHENTIC
LIVES AND INSTEAD THEIR FAITH
THE AMERICAN DREAM WAS MET WITH
CONTEMPT AND DERISION.
I WANT TO SAY TO EVERYBODY WHO
IS FLEEING PERSECUTION
ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO ARE FLEEING
PERSECUTION BECAUSE OF WHO THEY
LIVE AND WHO THEY ARE.
WE SEE YOU.
YOU ARE WELCOME HERE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON AG ARE.
NINETEEN THANK YOU ASSESSMENT
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON THIS MATTER MISTER
GORE YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I WANT.
TO EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION TO
OUR FELLOW LEGISLATIVE CAUCUSES
THIS RESOLUTION HAS UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT OF OUR ETHNIC CAUCUSES --
AND I THINK THAT THAT'S A
POWERFUL STATEMENT ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF IMMIGRATION OF
PROVIDING SAFE REFUGE TO THOSE.
WHO NEED A PLACE TO COME AND I
WOULD JUST ASK YOU TO CONSIDER
AGAIN THE HISTORIC LEVELS OF?
NINETY FIVE THOUSAND THAT HAVE
BEEN REDUCED BY THIS
ADMINISTRATION.
TO THIRTY THOUSAND THEY'RE
CURRENTLY ONLY AT ELEVEN
THOUSAND WE'RE HALFWAY THROUGH
THE YEAR.
EVERY UNFULFILLED SEAT IS A
BREAKING OF OUR COMMITMENT TO
THE WILL COMMUNITY.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY IS
DISRUPTING THE LIVES OF PEOPLE
WHO NEED SOME PLACE TO GO.
MY COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES
TALKED ABOUT THE VERY TRAGIC WAY
THAT THIS IS PLAYING OUT AND THE
RIO GRANDE RIVER.
MY COLLEAGUE FROM TO MY FELLOW
COLLEAGUES IN SAN DIEGO TALKED
ABOUT THE VALUE THAT REFUGEES
CAN BRING TO OUR COMMUNITY.
AND SO THINK ABOUT THE TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF MISSED
OPPORTUNITIES OF LEADER LIVES
LOST OR GREATNESS DEFERRED
BECAUSE OF ADMINISTRATIONS
POLICIES AND SO AGE ARE NINETEEN
IS ABOUT SAYING THAT IN THE
UNITED STATES.
THAT THIS STATE STANDS WITH
REFUGEES INTO MAKING FOR FOR
FILLING OUR COMMITMENT UNDER THE
LAW AND MAKING SURE THAT THE
GREATNESS OF THIS NATION IS NOT
LEFT ON A RIVER BANK OR IN A
CAMP IN A FAR AWAY WORLD.
BUT REALLY FOR FILLING A
COMMITMENT THAT HAS MADE US AT%
THE BEST COUNTRY ON EARTH
MEMBERS I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
ON HR. NINETEEN SIX WHERE WOULD
YOU LIKE THE FIRST ROLE TO BE
OPEN FOR QATAR'S YES MINISTRY.
WELL OPEN THE AUTHORS.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
THE ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
SAYS FOR CO AUTHORS.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY VOTE THERE ARE FIFTY FIVE
CO AUTHORS ON EACH YEAR.
NINETEEN THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE FOR A VOTE JAN.
NINETEEN ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ON MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE THERE ARE THE I
FIFTY SIX NO ZERO AJ ARE
NINETEEN IS ADOPTED.
MOVING BACK TO CONCURRENCE IS
FILE ITEM FORTY TWO AB.
ONE EIGHTY EIGHT THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL ONE EIGHTY
EIGHT PRICE ONLY MEMBER DALY AND
ACTUALLY TO INSURANCE.
MR DAILY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER IN
MEMBERS.
THERE ARE CIRCUMSTANCES IN WHICH
A HOMEOWNER INSURED WITH AN
ACTUAL CASH VALUE POLICY
RECEIVES A LARGER PAYMENT FOR A
PARTIAL LOSS OF THEIR HOME.
THEN THEY WOULD FOR A TOTAL LOSS
OF THEIR HOME THIS BILL CORRECTS
THAT AND EMILY.
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS WERE
TECHNICAL IN NATURE I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
YOU MISTER DALY SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE
MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE -- MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR
TO VOTE -- MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE.
BURKE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY VOTE I SIXTY NEW ZEROS.
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
WITH.
FILE ITEM FORTY THREE AB TWO OH
FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO OH FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALY AND
ACTUALLY THE ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES
MR DAILY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THIS BILL IS EQUALLY IMPORTANT.
TO THE PREVIOUS BILL.
IT UPDATE STATE LOTTERY FLEXION
CHANGES IN FEDERAL LAW MADE
THIRTEEN YEARS AGO ROOM
REGARDING THE VARIOUS
INGREDIENTS THAT CAN BE ADDED TO
BEER.
SENATE AMENDMENTS WERE TACTICAL
IN THE BILL AS RECEIVE NO
OPPOSITION.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER DALY SEEING
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE
MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
QUIRK WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY THREE NO
ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED WITH.
FILE ITEM FORTY FOUR AB TWELVE
EIGHTY NINE THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY WILL TWELVE EIGHTY NINE
BY SOME REMEMBER CHEN AND ACT
LIKE PROFESSIONS AND VOCATIONS.
MR JANUARY RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER.
AB IT WILL BE NICE BACK THE
SENATE ON CONCURRENT WITH MINOR
CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS AB TOLD
WHEN I WILL SPECIFY IT IS ON THE
ARMS CONGRESS LEGAL
RESPONSIBILITY. TO OBTAIN LOCAL
USE PERMITS THIS BILL RECEIVE
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT IN BOTH HOUSES
RESPECT THE AFTER I VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAN SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE
MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
WHERE WELL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY NINE NEWS
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS CONCURRED
WITH?
WE HAVE AN ADDITIONAL GUEST
INTRODUCTION TODAY MISS EGGMAN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GUEST INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU ADMINISTRATOR MEMBERS --
TODAY IT IS MY GREAT PLEASURE TO
WELCOME THE LEAD ON CLASS FOR A
CALIFORNIA PISTACHIO GROWERS
FIRST MEMBER SOME FUN FACTS
ABOUT PISTACHIOS.
DID YOU KNOW THAT 98% OF THE
PISTACHIOS PRODUCED IN THE
UNITED STATES COME FROM
CALIFORNIA.
AND DID YOU KNOW THAT PISTACHIOS
ARE TWO OF THE OLDEST FLOWERING
TREES IN THE WORLD ONE OF ONLY
TWO NOT MENTIONED IN THE BIBLE.
AND AT LAKE WAS ABLE TO BE.
PLANTED IN THE GARDENS OF
BABYLON.
AND SAID TO BE THE FAVORITE OF
QUEEN SHEBA.
SO UP STATUTES HAVE A LONG IN A
BROIL HISTORY IN THE WORLD WE
ARE PROUD OF THAT THEY ARE ONE
OF THE THE MAJOR CROPS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND WE ARE ALSO PROUD TODAY THAT
WE HAVE THE LEAD ON CLASS --
LEADERSHIP CLASS INTO THE
CAPITAL TODAY WE DON'T IS A YEAR
LONG PROGRAM DESIGNED TO PROVIDE
LEADERSHIP TRAINING AND
EDUCATIONAL SEMINARS TO HELP
STATURE GROWERS TO BECOME BETTER
EQUIPPED TO MAKE AN IMPACT ON
THE FORMS COMMUNITIES AND THE
STATE.
THEY'RE ONE OF THE TOP. TEN
CROPS OF CALIFORNIA AND PLEASE
MEMBERS HELP ME WELCOME -- THE
LEAD ON TO STASH YOUR GROWERS
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WELCOME TO OUR GAS.
MOVING TO THAT CONSENT CALENDAR.
FILE ITEMS.
EIGHTY FIVE TO NINETY NINE DOES
ANY MEMBER WHICH TO REMOVE AN
ITEM FROM
.
DOES ANY MEMBER WHICH TO REMOVE
AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING NINE THE
CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND A
CONSENT CALENDAR.
SOMETHING CURRENT VERSION ONE OF
FOUR BY SOME MEMBER BONDS AND
OTHERS MELTED THE PHILIPPINE
INDEPENDENCE DAY.
THERE ARE RESOLUTIONS ON TODAY'S
CONSENT CALENDAR WE WILL OPEN
THE ROLE TO ADD CO AUTHORS TO
THOSE RESOLUTIONS.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
HOUSE RESOLUTION FORTY THREE BY
SOME REMEMBER CHOI RELATIVE THE
SIXTY NINTH ANNIVERSARY OF THE
KOREAN WAR.
CLERK WILL OPEN THEIR OFFER CO
AUTHOR.
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTIONS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLAIRE WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THAT THEIR SIXTY SEVEN CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTIONS ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THE CLERK WILL NOW OPEN THE ROLE
IN THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE VERY VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE IT
THIS IS A VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY SEVEN NO
ZERO BECAUSE AND CALENDARS
ADOPTED THE CLERK WILL READ THE
REMAINING ITEMS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
HOUSE RESOLUTION FORTY THREE I
SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO SIMPLE THREE
TWENTY TWO I SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO
THREE THIRTY FOUR I SIXTY SEVEN
NO ZERO SIMPLE. THREE SIXTY SIX
SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO SIMPLE THREE
EIGHTY THREE I SIXTY SEVEN IS
THERE A SINGLE THREE NINETY NINE
I SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO SIMPLE
THREE TWENTY FOUR I SIXTY SEVEN
NO ZERO SYMBOL THREE SEVENTY
NINTHS URGENCY.
I SIXTY SEVEN IS THERE ON THE
URGENCY AYE SIXTY SEVEN IS HERE
ON THE BILL SIMPLE THREE EIGHTY
WITH URGENCY I SIXTY SEVEN NOTES
HERE ON THE URGENCY AYE SIXTY
SEVEN KNOWS THERE ON THE BILL
SIMPLE THREE EIGHTY ONE I SIXTY
SEVEN NO ZERO CYNICAL.
SIX FORTY SIX I SIXTY SEVEN IS
ZERO SENATE CONCURRENT AGE FIFTY
EIGHT I SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO AND
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
FORTY SEVEN AYE SIXTY SEVEN NO.
ZERO MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS THE
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS.
FRIDAY JUNE TWENTY THERE'S NO
FLOOR SESSION AND CHECK IN
SESSION MONDAY JULY FIRST FLOOR
SESSION AT ONE PM.
IN THE ABSENCE OF AN INJECTION
THE QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED.
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO THE
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
THE FLOOR.
QUORUM CALL IS LEFT IN.
MEMBERS WE ASK THAT YOU TAKE
YOUR SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR
.
THANK YOU MEMBER THIS THE
FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE GRANTED
PRIOR PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON A
GERMAN IN MEMORY.
MISS RIVAS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
YOUR GERMAN IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO ADJOURN
IN MEMORY OF LAUREL SHOCKLEY.
MISAKI WAS A RESIDENT OF MY
DISTRICT IN A WELL KNOWN LEADER
IN ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT SHE
SERVED A SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON'S ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
ADVISOR FOR SEVERAL REGIONS
ACROSS.
THE STATE INCLUDING THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY.
BEFORE SHE JOINED SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON SHE WAS THE
DIRECTOR OF STRATEGIC LOCATION.
AND EXPANSION SERVICES FOR KPMG
A FINANCIAL ADVISING FIRM WITH
EMPLOYEES AND PARTNERS
THROUGHOUT THE U. S. IN HER LONG
AND DISTINGUISHED CAREER MISS
SHOCKLEY HELD VARIOUS POSITIONS.
AND A PLETHORA OF ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT ORGANIZATIONS
INCLUDING.
AS THE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRADE AND COMMERCE
AGENCIES SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
REGIONAL OFFICE MEMBER OF THE LA
COUNTY WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD AND THE GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEE IN THE CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING PANEL AMONG
MANY OTHER POSITIONS.
THE ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
COMMUNITY AND ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
THIRTY NINE WILL MISS MISS
SHOCKLEY AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
THAT WE ADJOURN IN HER MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISS RIVAS.
MR CHOI YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMAN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
AND THE MEMBERS IT IS SO WITH
THE SOLEMN NEWS THAT I STAND
TODAY. TO REQUEST THAT THOUGHT
WE ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF A
MEMBER OF THE UPGRADE USED A
GENERATION.
RETIRED THE LIEUTENANT CONNOR.
ROBERT CRANDALL A REST ON OF MY
DISTRICT IN THE CITY OF IRVINE
SINCE.
NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO ROBERT DOLE
WHO OP WENT BY BOB.
WITH HIS FRIENDS SO PASSED AWAY
THIS ALLOWS FOR FRIDAY.
AT THE GREAT AGE -- FOR NINETY
NINE YEARS OLD.
BOB WAS SOMEONE OF THE ELEVEN
REMAINING TUSKEGEE AIRMEN WHO
FLEW IN WARD WAS.
TOO MANY OF US KNOW THAT -- AT
THE BEGINNING OF WOULD WANT.
TO THE GOVERNMENT DECIDED TO
ALLOW AFRICAN AMERICANS TO FLY
IN THE AIR CORPS.
BUT THE IN AN ALL BLACK US
SQUADRON KNOWN AS THE TUSKEGEE
AIRMEN.
NAMED AFTER THE TUSKEGEE ARMY
AIR FIELD WE HAD THE SQUADRON
WAS TRAY AND THROUGH THE BLOODY
AND THE DECISIVE ABOUT HOURS SO
I IN.
ONE ONE TWO BOB.
FLEW ON ASTOUNDING ONE HUNDRED
FORTY TO COMBAT MISSIONS.
THIS EMISSIONS OFTEN NOT
INVOLVED.
THE ESCORT OF OBAMA'S REQUIRING
HIM TIME AND TIME MAKE AGAIN TO
PLACE HIMSELF IN HARM'S WAY TO
PROTECT THE OUTLET THOUGH.
PLAY THIS.
AFTER WORLD WAR TWO BOB STAYED
THE IN THE NEW AIR FORCE AND THE
CONTINUED TO HIS -- EXEMPLARY
SERVICE SAW IN THE KOREAN WAR
AND THE WAR IN VIETNAM.
AFTER TWENTY EIGHT YEARS OF OF
DISTINGUISHED SERVICE MATAN
CONNELL.
ROBERT THE FRIEND THE RETIRED TO
TO WORK ON AS A PROFIT.
OUR SPACE A CONTRACTOR WORKING
ON MANY PROJECTS -- INCLUDING
THE SPACE SHUTTLE PROGRAM.
BY HIS SIDE LIFETIME OF A
SELFLESS SERVICE.
IS SO AMAZING MAN LEFT A LEGACY
FOR THIS COUNTRY AS WELL AS OF
FOR HIS CHILDREN.
GRAND CHILDREN AND GREAT GREAT
CHILDREN.
BOB WILL BE REMEMBERED AS A TRUE
AMERICAN HERO.
AND THE WOULD BE MESSED UP BY
MANY.
AND THEN I THINK OF POP A SAID
THE SAID IT BEST WHEN HE SAID.
I NEVER FELT THAT I WAS SAW
ANYTHING BUT ON AMERICAN DOING
OUR JOB.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK.
THAT THE WE ADJOURN IN HIS
MEMORY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHOI.
MEMBERS PLEASE BRING THE NAMES
THE DESK BE PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL ALL REQUESTS FOR JOURNEY
MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED READ.
AND PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED ENTERTAINED ALL MOTION
SHOULD BE CONTINUED SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER BUSINESS I'M
READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
ADJOURN.
MR BONTA MOVES IN MISTER
GALLAGHER SECOND FOR THIS HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL MONDAY
JULY FIRST AT ONE PM
.
VOTE CHANGE RAMOS.
AB.
NINETY SEVEN FROM I TO NOT
VOTING.
THE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS
ITALY BILL NINETY SEVEN HI TO
NOT VOTING